yes we have heard it over and over again
this will be the titan version of batman
vs superman and a rematch of the 1962
king kong vs godzilla these are the two
movies that this upcoming flick will be
held
up against now what if i say that those
aren't the only movies but a total of 11
others that are combined to form this
epic masterpiece of march 2021
it's infinity war it's aquaman its
pacific rim and others together in one
with various aspects of all these movies
taken out and converted into templates
and scenes that will appear
and theorize to appear in godzilla vs
calm
so in this video we will do our best to
compare what we have seen and heard
alongside the other movie scenes that
influenced this film
so smash that subscribe button and get
us to 200 000 subscribers before the
release of this movie
now let's get this started number one
gong is
chained up and dropped and made to fight
godzilla well this one is obvious as the
trailer goes and we can see that kong is
sedated and unconscious transported on a
big
ship towards the mainland or some other
location from skull island
humans seem to think that only kong is
worried enough to beat godzilla
the trailer seen as heavily influenced
by many of kong's movies but most
notable
the scene of kong being tied up on top
of a wooden wrath in king kong vs
godzilla of 1962
where he is taken from to japan for the
same reason to fight godzilla
number two godzilla vs kong vs mecca
godzilla as we all know by now people
have been comparing the upcoming movie
to the dc universe batman vs superman
since government godzilla are basically
good guys in the monsterverse it would
not make sense for them to fight to the
death
so as we have seen in the trailer
mechagodzilla does appear in the scene
and we will hopefully get a batman vs
superman vs doomsday kind of battle in
the end
spoilers and leaked plots however
trustful they are stands to back this up
number three kong fights hellhounds in
the later scenes of the trailer we see
kong standing up on top of a shiny
glowing surface of what seems to look
like godzilla
but at the same time we see a bunch of
hell hogs new bat like kaiju that will
appear in the movie
and they seem to be attacking kong from
all sides well this scene is heavily
influenced from the one where kong
fights the therapist more dax bats
on top of a cliff in king kong 2005 bats
and kong do not like each other at all i
see
especially with camazotz in the upcoming
comics
number 4 bright and colorful battle
scenes most of us has always been less
glam
about its fight scenes and more
animalistic from the dark and
suspenseful
2014 battle with their mutos to the
1970s theme com where he battles the
skull crawlers
and the king of the monsters where it
looked kind of modern but still dark
we get a change in the trailer with
battle scenes becoming more colorful
and more bright as in the battles of the
kaiju vs jaegers of the movie pacific
rim
and its successor the pacific rim
uprising
number 5 kong fights warbad the snake
titan
of course what kind of movie is there
where kong doesn't battle giant snakes
from the son of kong to the 1976 remake
we see gong fight giant serpents all the
time
the fight with the warbats might be
reminiscent of his earlier battles with
most notably
the one with a giant boa from the king
kong movie of 1976.
how the bell takes place however and the
action scenes however
is a different story since the earlier
movies were made with suits and
animatronics
without the use of cgi number 6 gom's
battle axe against the atomic breath
this is the one scene which broke the
internet well sort of
this is the one where gom and godzilla
fights in a major city
and kong wields a very powerful battle
axe that he has to retrieve from the
hollow earth in order to stand a chance
against the nuclear lizard during the
battle godzilla is seen shooting his
iconic
power move the atomic breath but the axe
deflects it and absorbs the energy up to
a point where kong is able to run it to
the face of the g-man
this is obviously from the mcu universe
infinity war where thor throws the storm
breaker acts against the energy beam
shot from the infinity gauntlet
wielded by thanos in the movie infinity
war
number seven hollow earth and portals
and retrieving the ancient weapon
in the trailer and the encrypted scenes
of king of the monsters we can see that
the hollow earth is real
in the monsterverse and that it is only
accessible from certain portals in the
oceans or other unstable regions
even in the trailer we can see kong
fighting and unraveling his past inside
a hollow earth
where there's sort of a hidden world
that isn't dark and dingy
well we can clearly see the same thing
in the movie aquaman
as aquaman travels from the trench via a
storm slash portal
to the center of the world in order to
retrieve the trident
which resonates with kong going there to
the hollow earth to get the balance
as it was forged by his ancestors
number eight godzilla destroys fighter
jets and the tail
scene okay this next one might be a bit
of a guess and you might say
i'm looking for things and seeing clues
where none exists
like searching for ancient aliens but i
[ __ ] you not
if you have seen shin godzilla of 2016
then
at the very beginning it was seen just
as a tale i mean shin godzilla was just
seen as a tale in the ocean and the
mobility and agility of the tail
can be compared to the trailer of
godzilla vs kong when godzilla attacks
the fighter jets using his own tail
and with moves in a similar fashion like
a leech that senses its prey
and moves upwards and moves accordingly
number nine mechagodzilla might be
created from ghidorah
so let's now go through the theories for
godzilla vs gong
as we have seen at the end of the king
of the monsters there is that one head
of ghidorah that was left
out after the battle in the ocean of the
coast of mexico
they fished that out and alan jonah an
antagonist of the film
now has bought it from the fishermen
over there so
to what extent it will be used is yet
unknown but i'm 90
sure that it will be used to power and
steer mechagodzilla
and this idea wouldn't be new it would
be taken from godzilla vs maker godzilla
2
where the damage head of mecca king
ghidorah was salvaged and used to build
supermaker godzilla
number 10 mecha godzilla might be
created from the bones of dagon
so continuing from the theory of using
ghidorah's head to build mechagodzilla
the overall structure of the mechanized
titan could be constructed based on the
template from the skeletal remains
of dagon as was seen in the beginning of
the scenes of
godzilla 2014. dagon was one of
godzilla's ancestors that died
battling the muter prime this would be
inspired from the movie godzilla against
mechagodzilla 2002 as kiryu mecha
godzilla
was built using the bones from the
original godzilla that died in 1954
from the oxygen destroyer weapon number
11 behemoth is killed by mechagodzilla
so this last one is based on a theory
that we have put forth
where we saw behemoth a toy image that
was leaked and it means that the titan
would appear
in the movie but to what extent is yet
unknown so the theory is that
since behemoth is has bowed down to
godzilla as the king of all the titans
it would be subservient to him
and counted as an ally it might be
killed by mechagodzilla in order to
frame godzilla for the ongoing attacks
and the death of this titan would be
like when anguirus is killed by
mechagodzilla while he was still in his
hidden form as godzilla in godzilla vs
mechagodzilla from 1974
so that's about it the list of the 11
movie scenes and plots that would
heavily influence the storyline
and action sequences of godzilla vs gong
2021
and with that we come to the end of the
video do hit that like button for
support
and smash that subscribe button to get
us to 200k
and while you're at it slap that
notification bell as well
for regular updates on the monster
videos till the next one
take care fam